[musique]
pour la plupart c'est un dialogue fli doux-amer
dépend de l'alcool que vous buviez
un peu d'eau est particulièrement vrai pour n'importe qui
bloc arbre galice et malgré configuré
reste le même petit serviteur de la sobriété
un appartement
pour l'instant un parti de gauche d'abord
la pensée qui m'est venue
nom chic pour lui
s'amuser parce que tout est foutu
l'isolement lui-même prend vie, il y a encore des faiblesses
bien sûr le temps général vraiment
très confortable à gonfler
[musique]
[applaudissements]
cette situation difficile que tout le monde
les patients anxieux les ont juste
le niveau d'anxiété a dépassé l'échelle le niveau de phobie
tous ceux qui étaient dépendants ont commencé
utiliser parce qu'ils
la seule façon de se détendre est
l'alcool donc juste une rafale d'appels
quoi faire prendre rendez-vous avec un psychothérapeute
venez pour la prescription nous très lourd
situation en termes de psychiatrie et
narcologie
[musique]
serré peur de cette fois parce que
les gens se sont assis suffisamment, pouvez-vous imaginer
il y aura un jour férié les gens ont raté pâques
Jour de la victoire
tous les kebabs et mai, apparemment
ils le laisseront passer et puis il sera soudainement autorisé à
ces vannes ouvriront cette avalanche
allez j'ai peur d'une onde secondaire
réinfection quand ils commencent activement
communiquer et bien sûr ils marcheront comme s'ils n'étaient pas dans
auto cornoval vénitien juste
repos
[musique]